all right
welcome everyone this morning
who's joining us here in the audience
live in berlin and also to those joining
via the live stream today
my name is katharina i have a background
in computer science
i've been a data scientist for the last
eight years or so i'm in freelance for
the last five years for my freelance
clients i build all kinds of data
science and software solutions i also do
a whole bunch of open source work so if
that sounds interesting to you
reach out to me chat with me after you
talk or reach out to me via email
if you search
for
what skills
do i need to have to work as a data
scientist
or
data science interview questions one
thing that always comes up
is sql
yeah that's fair
rare is the data science jobs where you
don't have to query for your data that
you want to analyze rare is also the
python backend engineering job we are
not working with databases in some kind
of fashion
today
i don't want to talk all that much about
sql at all i want you to encourage to
take a bit of a broader picture and look
a bit more at the system that you're
sending
those queries to namely the database
management system because no
databases they're kind of running the
world right
nearly every service nearly every
venture imaginable be it an e-commerce
site be it bookkeeping software be it
manufacturing be it government services
they all need to store data and they all
do that in a database system
so there's probably millions i guess of
those installed throughout the world
the vast absolute vast majority of which
are relational database systems
there are other systems
for example there's things called like
graph databases and nosql databases but
today let's have a look at relational
database systems again those are the
vast majority of the databases that are
installed throughout the world
and you know what
the material that i'm going to present
to you today
it's from the 1970s
50 years old
still going strong
still running the world
and i think that warrants a closer look
but of course i took a database database
class back in university it took like
five months came with a big proper exam
and a textbook like this
today we have 45 minutes
so
i present you with what i would call a
refreshingly simple agenda
um
i
want to just focus
on two things i want to tell you about
the relational model and the relational
algebra and that sounds all muffy and
formal right now but i promise you i'll
keep it lightweight
and i'll show you how the relational
model builds a beautifully simple
abstraction a way of expressing data
on which on top of which engineers and
researchers have built all kinds of
nifty solutions
to make your lives easier when dealing
with data and one of those
i will be talking about today which is
the query planner which is what is
happening when you are sending a query
to your database system
but first
let's get started with the relational
model and the relational algebra
throughout this presentation i'm going
to be using this very simple database
you would
see something like similar to this in
some kind of e-commerce system probably
so we have a table it's called product
where we have one row per product and
for each product we know the product id
we know a category the name of the
product maybe there's a description and
a price as well and we have a second
table
called category which maps category ids
to the name of the category and maybe a
nice little icon to display on the
website you see there is this link this
relationship between product and
category so you can look up for your
category all the info id all the
information about the category of that
product
all right and that's it that's actually
it relational model is nothing more than
that all data is expressed as tables
and relationships between those tables
in the original paper which is from 1970
the
they'll
author
a slightly different language a table
isn't called a table it's called the
relation and that is where the name
relational database is coming from a row
isn't called a row it's called a tuple
and a column isn't called the timeline a
column it is called an attribute in the
tuple let's keep using our the language
we are now more used to tables rows and
columns
but again that's all there is to the
relational model all data is expressed
as tables and relationships between
these tables
and then the relational algebra
is operations on these tables
let's look at our product table again
let's say we are only
interested in some of the columns in
this table
that operation is called the projection
it takes as input
your table
and produces another table that only
contains the columns that you need
and of course you probably all know that
right it's nothing more than the list of
columns you're interested in in your
select statement
similarly
there's an operation called the
selection
which only grabs the rows that you need
that match some condition that you have
specified
again you all know that it is just the
where clause clause within your sql
statement
so you've probably seen that i'm using
greek symbols here for both the
projection and the selection that is
just to give you a hint that everything
i'm talking about right now in the
original paper is defined in a way more
formal setting
so there is some kind of formal model
behind all of that but let's let's not
bother with those details today
a third operation you probably also all
know it's called the join we're
combining two tables
so here we looked up for our product
table we looked for each of the product
we looked up the name of the category
that product is in and we see again you
probably know that from your work with
sql we see the keyword join there in our
query
we're joining the product and category
and we're saying on which column to join
meaning
which column they both have
in common
and where we that we can use to match
the data from one table to the data of
the other table
there's a few more not all that many
just a handful more of operations
but they all have in common they all
take as input one or two tables
and as output they produce another table
it's an
extremely simple model we have
data expressed in tables and we have
operations that take tables and they
produce table and it's just that
simplicity that allows us
to make way more complex queries because
since all of these operations have the
same interface
you can just combine them however you
wish you can take a table
take grab do a projection grab only a
few columns join that up with another
table followed by a selection only a few
rows of the table and have another join
can mix it and match as much as you want
and yeah
sometimes you might be going too far
with that
probably most of us have had to debug a
query like this at some point
during our career
yeah and you see the scroll bars also in
both directions there
little side note did you know
that even the metadata about the table
so the thing that describes the table
is in a table so here i'm using postgres
and it has a database called information
schema
which has a table called columns and i
can just send a select query
to that table so here i'm interested in
the name and the data type of
the columns in this in my
table product so i'm sending a query to
information schema.columns with a
selection or where clause table name
equals product and as a result well i
get a table
and that table contains for example the
row that i have a column named id it's
the first column in my table it's an
integer i have a column named
name it's the third column in my table
and it is of type character varying
which is just another word for string
so it's just it really is just tables
it's tables all the way
down
now you might be just kind of
scratching your head a bit and we like
all right
so what because it does feel very
natural
to have data and tables right
but of course this doesn't the hindsight
is 2020 this doesn't this it wasn't
always that natural before
relational database systems i remember
those came up in the 1970s people were
always writing their own custom storage
data storage solution so you'd had your
program and there was no database you
could give your program to you'd have to
take the data find a suitable data
format to store that data and if
your program changed considerably you
would have to write
custom data transformation logic to make
the data that you had stored
match to the data that you need in your
system
relational databases actually weren't
the first attempt
at making
a system that is independent of the data
that you want to store there was also
something called
hierarchical database systems
um the idea was there that you model
data in a hierarchical system for
example you have a department which is
made up of the out of different teams
and each team has
these people in but it turned out that
this was too limiting a data model only
there was a lot of data that you
couldn't fit into this hierarchical
schema was only when relational
databases came up
with
a way of representing data that actually
works for a broad
broad range of data
that we achieved something
that the researchers called data
independence so the independence of
the data that you
that you're working with from the way it
is stored as long as you can fit
your data
into a table into this relational model
of tables relationships between those
tables then you don't need to care
how they are stored
you give them to your database system
and it takes care of all of that for you
so we have seen relational model it's
extremely simple
way
of thinking about data tables relations
between the tables and operations that
take the tables and now i want to show
how
thanks to that simple
data model that simple interface
fantastic solutions like the query
planner exist in the databases today
that you're using probably daily
so
let's think again about our two tables
we have a table product and we have our
table category and let's let's make it a
bit more fun let's say your product
table now it doesn't have three products
you're selling ten thousand products
but you still only have three categories
and let's do a bit more complex query
here
and this query it will
look up uh you basically you're
interested in for the product named
genes what is the name of the category
that product is in so let's let's take
apart this query let's look at what
operations we can find in here
we see a join
we join in between product and category
on that column that they have in common
the category id
we also see a selection we have a where
clause and we're only interested in
products
that
have the name genes
and we also have a projection in the end
we're only interested in the category
name
so we have three operations
but the question is
what order should we execute them in
and also
does it matter kind of is the result
going to be the same whatever the order
we actually we execute a query in
let's try it out
you know this this lo this join is
looking mighty fine at me let's try
let's try starting with that one
so as we do the join what what is
happening is
your database system is going through
all of the product table
and for each row it's look going through
all of the category table to look for
the category with the right id and then
it just matches those columns onto the
onto the row
we get
a table like that which is quite long we
have 10 000 rows and we have all of the
columns combined of both the product
table and the category table
next up let's do a selection
so we're only interested in rows where
the product name is jeans in our case
that is just one row
finally
comes our projection
we're only interested in the name of the
category so we're only keeping that
column so our result of the three
operations is a table with one row and
one column
but let's let's reconsider what we just
did
we
build up this
huge
table with 10 000 rows and all of the
columns and we did a lot of work doing
that
and then we just threw it all away
we only kept one row
and then we only kept one column that
doesn't seem very efficient does it
so let's try that again
this time
let's start with our selection
so
from the product table let's keep only
the rows that contain genes
so just one row and now of course our
drawing is much more simple instead of
having to go through all of the rows in
that table
we can
we just have to do it for one row
look up the right category
and we get as a result of that join a
table that contains only one row a whole
bunch of columns
finally we do the projection we only
keep one column the name of the category
and yes we have exactly the same result
as the previous one but we probably did
a bit more work more a bit more
efficiently both in times in terms of
cpu usage as well as memory usage
because we kind of have to keep all of
those intermediary tables also in memory
right
and if you have some time think about
could we also start with the projection
what would happen then
for now
i want to tell you
that you don't have to care about these
things
because that is exactly what the query
planner does so you send it that sql
query
and then it does just what we just did
it devises
execution plans so it takes apart that
query looks what kind of operations are
in there
and tries to find all possible
combinations
of operations and quite simple with the
query we just we just saw but the one
earlier from stack overflow the
screenshot probably has to work quite a
bit or query planner
it then
again does exactly what we just did it
tries to approximate the cost of
executing the query and that cost
is is not in
really it's some kind of abstract
measure it's not in terms of actual
money but in terms of cpu time memory
consumption running time of the query
all of which at some point of course
translate
into money
the query planner does it exactly like
we did it knows it keeps statistics
about your tables it knows
number of rows in your table number of
columns in your table for each column it
knows how many distinct values there are
for numeric attribute it keeps
statistics about the spread of the data
to be able to get an idea of does it
make sense to do the selection between
before the join or the other way around
and give you an approximate cost of the
query
finally again just like we did it picks
the best plan
you might be asking now okay have i
interacted with such a thing before do
all database system systems have a query
planner
and the answer is kind of yes of course
there's thousands of these systems out
there all the big
classic relational systems such as
oracle
postgres mysql sqlite even they all have
a query planner
in terms of when you talk when we're
talking about data warehouse systems on
the cloud
google cloud query bigquery it has a
query planner amazon redshift
redshift yes it also has a query planner
and you might even argue that for a
cloud database it's even more important
to actually have a query planner because
you want to avoid sending a bunch of
data around between the different nodes
that you in the end are just going to
throw away
and also actually
you can see what a query planner is
doing
here is an example from postgres so what
you can do is just
before your query you just put explain
and then you get an output like this and
this is the query plan
and it's a bit hard to decipher and i'll
admit i've rarely needed to use that
most of the times the query planner is
doing a really good jobs it's only
sometimes that a query is taking so long
and you're running it all the time and
you're getting so frustrated and that's
probably when you want to be looking at
the query planner to see what's going on
so let's try to dig a bit into what's
happening here
the first thing we see
is our selection and it's not called the
selection here but we can see that
that's what hap with what's happening
because we have this filter there the
name should be genes
we also see the join so we're joining
between the result of our selection and
the category table which is the lowest
row
and it's called it's not called a join
here it's a nested loop and we saw
earlier that's exactly what we're doing
right we're going through the product
table and try to find the rows matching
rows in the category table
and then we have the cost of this query
you get a range of the of the cost and
here is actually quite an expensive
query so this is not it doesn't cost 200
again it's some measure of of cpu memory
consumptions etc
basically you can only consider a cost
expensive by comparing against other
queries run on the same system
i'll tell you this one is expensive
right now and we can do better
if we
look a bit deeper we see that there's
one bit in the query that's causing all
of that cost and that is our selection
that we're doing in the first step
whereas then finding the right category
id a category row for each category id
that's actually pretty quick so what's
going on here
and the hint is this one
a sequential scan
let's look at what's happening there
different name for it would be table
scan it's a word i'm a bit more
comfortable with um
basically when
your database system is looking for
the right role in that database it has
to go through the whole table
which we know has 10 000 rows
to find only the one table that is
relevant and that is causing us causing
it all to take that long and to be that
expensive but we can do better
we can do is called creating an index
here we're creating an index on the
table product
in the column name
when basically what's that doing is
building another data structure another
view of looking at the data i presented
here as a dictionary it's not actually a
dictionary it's more like like a
tree-like structure
but i think this was a way of
visualizing this easier
so
instead of going from id to name now you
go the other way around so you know that
for example bread
is in row one you know that apple is in
row two and ten thousand and you know
that jeans is in row three and now of
course instead of having to do this
whole table scan you don't need to do
that anymore you can just look up
in which row
your relevant attributes are
so let's look at a query plan before
and after doing that
so on top is the query plan we saw we
saw before at the bottom is the query
plan after we have added the index
we see one thing has changed instead of
the sql sequential scan we now have an
index scan
and our cost
decreased drastically like we are 10
cost f of what we were
before
and also all over all cost then
decreased considerably
so now you might be thinking all right
that's pretty useful
can we just have it index for every
column and then everything we query
could be fast
but of course there's always weighing
off of of different considerations right
and here you need to consider
first the storage overhead so instead of
just keeping one table in storage now
you also need to keep this other this
index data structure in storage
somewhere and you need to do that for
every column
and then you need to consider what
happens when you add a new row to the
database because now you're not just
inserting it into your product column
you're also inserting it into your index
and your index has also special features
for making queries quite fast so
it can take a while to to to add to the
to the index so you have both storage
overhead and insertion overhead so index
actually it only makes sense if this is
a column that you often query for
if you find yourself doing the same
query again again and it's always really
really slow then talk to your database
administrator and ask them
if it's possible to add an index to that
query to that column that you're using
in your selection or the column that
you're using in your join and it's
likely causing your query to be so
expensive
okay
like i mentioned earlier
a rather lightweight agenda also not to
overwhelm you with the details here
today there's of course many things
that i couldn't mention today one thing
i would have loved to mention is
how the relational model this
beautifully really simple abstraction
also helps you when inserting data so
things
like
constraints
for maintaining data integrity
constraints are only possible because
everything is in the table and we can
just simply say
this
column should have a constraint we
should not have any null values in there
because we have this data independence
and it's possible
to just say these things to just say
columns should not be no without having
to know much about the underlying data
um
simple similarly transactions which help
you when there's concurrent access to
the database again they are greatly
aided by us having this lovely
abstraction
and finally there's this whole big thing
of well how do we actually find the
tables that fit our data so that is
entity relationships diagrams data
normalization so ways of modeling your
data as a table which i think is
probably a 45-minute talk at least
in its own right
so i'll keep it with at this for today
take away that the relational model and
relational algebra is beautifully simply
simple but extremely powerful
abstraction
and one of the important things it gives
us
is data independence
which then
enables us to build cool things on top
like for example the query planner
you can reach me by email and my slides
are already online on my github thank
you
[Applause]
thank you catherine
uh
okay i'm supposed to moderate the qa
session uh through
slido okay
but i don't see any question at the
moment so we are i know we can do also
the old-fashioned way question
yeah thank you for the great talk uh i
have one question uh you said it's due
to the or it's the job of that of the
database designer to decide which
columns are to have an index but can't
the databases decide on their own they
can do some statistics on which column
has been queried how often and then
decide to set up an index or throw the
old ones away is this done
it sounds like a great idea so great
that probably somebody has done that i
don't know
i'm convinced
so hopefully somebody has done that
okay i was just speaking too quiet uh
yeah thank you for your great talk i
wanted to ask considering your past
experience what do you think is the
future for the relational databases will
they just fade away become obsolete like
everything in a software world or do you
think they will be improved and improved
iterated over and over again well i mean
like i said been going strong for for 50
years now and of course there's other
system nosql had a big big following in
the early 2010s seems to have quieted
down a little bit and it tries to solve
a slightly different problem right
relational database are a generalist
approach
general way of more of storing data
whereas no sql databases they are really
for very specific
types of data and specific types of
usages
from what i understand relational
databases actually have changed
after new sql databases came up to also
incorporate what they offer to the
people so it does seem to me that
there's still a lot of development in
the field and i'd say it's probably
something we're going to be using in the
in the in the future actually in in
legacy database in legacy system you see
still hierarchical databases hanging
around so probably not we're not going
to get rid of this technology so so
quickly
hello
thanks for your talk
i was wondering if you had some
additional resources that go maybe
beyond a little bit are but are still
like
i don't know let's say beginner friendly
for like
non-database experts and um yeah yeah i
would have loved to give you this and
maybe somebody else
else else knows i've looked for
something like this but it seems like
there's only
textbooks
and intro to sql
so
the middle ground i haven't really seen
well covered to be honest
which is a shame
thank you really much for your talk um
as someone who is working with google
bigquery sorry as someone who's working
with google bigquery i was interested if
you could elaborate elaborate a little
bit on the differences between
relational databases and warehouse
systems because i always thought google
bigquery is also kind of a relational m
system because it really feels like it
yeah it does feel like it right and i
mean this is it's kind of testament to
the strength of the relational algebra
that we're using
sql to query all kinds of database
systems it's the de facto standard
language for doing that even if maybe
the data behind is not actually stored
in a relational
manner so for for bigquery
it we are seeing tables and we're
running sql so we're doing relational
algebra i actually don't know what's
going on behind i don't think it's
stored as a classic relational system
because it's
really for
distributing data across many many nodes
which you can do in a relationship
system but i think it's optimized for
that so i i actually don't know but to
me it also feels like accessing just
any other relational
system yeah slider was better
hello um thank you for the talk i'm
right here um i have a naive technical
question i hope you don't mind
when you index that
column in the
whichever slide it was i forgot the
number um
when you have um different values in the
column such that it's comparable in the
size to the actual table
when you're getting the indices from
that you said it was not a hashmap or a
dictionary but something else we're
getting the values
uh indices from that structure
how is it that it's
reduces the cost so effectively because
as far as i mentioned it if you for
instance have all the different names in
that table
you have to go through all the different
names instead of going through all the
different
rows right so
why is it i mean i mean you're right an
index
it works best if you have in in case of
a categorical column like this if you
have very few distinct values that are
repeated over different rows
it is worth less
if if each row you if each value only
comes up once but still the tree like
structure gives you
something like an order of log n access
to that data whereas with the scalable
table scan you would get in the order of
n
access
to to the data so it still adds a little
bit but it's even better if you have
data that is compressed more
uh hi there uh thank you once again for
your presentation um just for those of
us who don't know could you briefly
explain the difference between a
hierarchical and a relation
relational database
you know
it's a very good question because i
asked my i asked that myself
in a way because there's very little
material on relational databases out
there so the idea
on on hierarchical databases out there
the idea really is that it's
data that you can model in a
hierarchical fashion where it's not
possible to so you can only have links
going from the top to the bottom but you
can have links between the different
elements or upwards of the tree and that
is quite restrictive to many use cases
but the one example the one with the
department
uh and the different teams that's
actually the one that's that that's
always given and i didn't dig any deeper
beyond this
hi um i wanted to piggyback off the
question about bigquery um someone told
me that it isn't necessary to index
tables in a data warehouse cloud data
warehouse any thoughts on that i'm sorry
i didn't i didn't get questions get the
question um someone told me that um
[Music]
indexing is not necessary for cloud data
warehouses do you have any thoughts on
that
it's not something i've worked with so
much i'm sorry i really don't know
other questions
no i just
otherwise would be not recorded or
streamed so
i i have a question uh like you
mentioned that index adding indexes is
not like uh best thing like for every
use case uh from your experience like
when you have a table that's updated
like regularly like like stream updated
uh does it make sense at adding indexes
like is there like a like from your
experience like a pain point when it
doesn't make sense to add indices
well i mean the
i think that's also that's that's why we
have the separation between
operational databases where you store
whatever data is coming in and data
warehouses where you then read from and
do analysis on
if you're streaming data and doing all
inserts all of the time then the index
is going to hurt you and then it's
probably the model where you want to
have a separate database like a data
warehouse that just copies over that
nightly or at higher frequencies
where you have indexes at the strategic
points that you don't need to add into
because this this database is read-only
basically
but it's i mean it's always use case by
use case dependent and you need to
hopefully you have some experienced
database administrator who can who can
help you out figuring
at what point it makes sense to switch
to a model like this
you should probably check the schleider
again as well yeah sorry is there
anything in this light or now
yeah no i just checked there is no
question slido all right
and
we still have some time for a few
questions if you will
hello thank you for your talk
do you have an opinion
between
[Music]
open source
sql database and uh
priority ones like oracle compared to
postgrade maybe in the engine behind or
the ability to look into the code
to understand how it works i mean i mean
thousands hundreds of thousands of
businesses are using using postgres uh
and are using mysql or maria db it seems
to be a very mature
technology
and
if the if the oracle salesman doesn't
give you any better arguments for why
you should be using oracle then i would
go open source
all right
questions
hi uh thanks for the great talk i was
wondering are there any difficulties or
are there any difficulties arising when
you are going to higher dimensional
databases like out of 2d to i don't know
3d for the nd
yeah this is probably where your
relational model is starting going to
start to crack and i mentioned earlier
something like like graph databases
right where where things
let's say you have a graph of the
friendships that people have and you
want to have queries such as who is the
friend of this person who is also a
friend of this person that's again one
of the
one of one of the things that
you can put in a database but it's
really hard to use the relational
algebra to use that data so
if
you can't find a way to normalize your
multi-dimensional data
downward towards two-dimensional
such that you still have expressivity in
your queries then yeah probably it's not
the right right tool there okay thank
you
questions
other questions
well
so i guess this is it thank you katrin
for your speech and your contribution
thank you